so i've got a tough one for you first
it's like the
one of the biggest questions about the
character but what would you say is the
key to finding the right balance between
making marla a protagonist that viewers
want to root for but also not sugar
coating the fact that she's doing
terrible things
one of the things um about a character
who's very unlikable
who keeps you on side is the fact that
you know
she's not asking anything of you she's
not asking you to like it she's not
asking you to feel for her
she's not suddenly halfway through the
movie delivering you a sort of tragic
backstory and saying well you know this
is why i'm like i am and i think
you know those are the kind of moves
that derail a character like this
um and and it's something i really
admire in the screenplay for not doing
um and you know
i think the other thing is is that as
well as sort of
realizing how shocking marla is we are
also simultaneously shocked with the
whole system that is set up for people
like her to win you know the only reason
marla can have this hustle
is because there's a loophole in the
american legal and
health care system that allows her to do
this you know she's not breaking the law
she's stretching it as
thin as a can go but she's not breaking
the law
she gets hurt way more than she hurts
actually which is quite interesting and
she's threatened with guns and she
the furthest she ever goes is a taser i
suppose that hurts but not
not an immortal way i know these are two
uh
very different stories but i think about
this movie often and i was wondering if
you ever thought about amy from gone
girl while you were doing this movie
just in terms of uh
i guess nailing the anti-hero nature of
it all
i've thought about amy now that i've
seen the film i didn't think about amy
while i was making the film
um i think
you know what they both do those
characters is is
is take traditional notions of
femininity the things that people expect
in their women the qualities
and use them to their advantage mimic
them you know portray them
very convincingly amy it's it's sort of
making herself the
tragic victim for the whole of america
and you think she is the victim until
you realize she's
controlling the whole story and with
marla she's
um you know she's very convincing in
court she's appears trustworthy an
upstanding citizen
you know who has the interest of the
people at heart she's responsible
reliable
she's a caretaker a caregiver and then
you realize she's none of those things
she's just
you know using these people for
everything she can get out of them
um and but but she's convincing at
role-playing and i think i
enjoy kind of
taking all those parts of being a woman
and sort of
using and abusing them it's it's as it's
an interesting and
unsettling place to play in as an as an
actor
i would hate to uh employ any of those
things in life but i think people do you
know and i think that's what's so
unsettling about these characters is
people think god you know
maybe i know someone like that and of
course you do you all do
yeah i haven't been able to stop
thinking about people potentially
abusing
the system like this and i might have
gone down the google rabbit hole of uh
looking things like that up
before i have to uh let you go i have
one other question about something that
might seem
like a little detail but i got very
obsessed with tracking
marla's use of her vape pen or rather
when she decides to use it and when she
doesn't so what is it like
incorporating such an active prop into
the character like that
well it's really fun um and the vape was
really obnoxious
and it kind of you know sometimes sort
of made very kind of aggressive kind of
growling noises and and sometimes you
know it
would come out of my nose or my mouth
and it would give me a dragon quality
which i i fully embraced
and used to affect um but you see the
back story of mahler is that she had a
vape business
until she was walmarted out of business
by a great big
discount vape store opening across the
street which she was furious about
and you know i think that was her shot
at the american dream played
played fair you know she had a small
time business she was a small-time
business owner she got screwed
and then she thought right chips are
down
i'm going all out i'm gonna i'm gonna
play the system like everybody else
and i think every time she inhales it's
kind of
it's it's bringing that that attitude to
it it's the attitude of having been
screwed and now you're out to screw
everybody
and not everyone would react like marla
does i mean i think she's
you know she's got that sort of uh
self-centered pride that
means that she doesn't believe she
should be screwed over
she deserves better she she won't be
she won't be like she says i won't lose
i don't lose i feel like that backstory
detail is only going to enhance the
effect of it
when i rewatch it thank you so much for
your time today and again huge
congratulations on the movie
please like it perry thanks